let's see if we can learn a thing or two
about the hyperbola hi / bola and out of
all of the conic sections this is
probably the one that confuses people
the most because it's not quite as easy
to draw as the circle and the ellipse
cuz you gotta do a little bit more
algebra but hopefully over the course
this video you'll get pre comfortable
with that and and you'll see that
hyperbola is in some way are are more
fun than any of the other conic sections
so just as a review and I want to I want
to do this just so you see the
similarity in the formulas or the kind
of the standard form of the different
conic sections if you have a conic a
circle centered at zero its equation is
x squared plus y squared is equal to R
squared and we saw that this could also
be written as and I'm doing this because
I want I wanted to show that this is
really just the same thing as the
standard equation for an ellipse if you
divide both sides of this by R squared
you get x squared over R squared plus y
squared over R squared is equal to 1 and
so this is a circle and once again it's
just review a circle all of the points
on the circle are equidistant from the
center or in this case you can kind of
say that the major axis and the Minor
axis are the same distance that there
isn't any distinction between the two
you're always an equal distance away
from the center so that was a circle and
ellipse was pretty much this but these
two numbers could be different because
your distance from the center could
change so it's x squared over a squared
plus y squared over B squared is equal
to 1 that's an ellipse and I you'll see
that a and I'll skip parabola for now
because parabola is kind of an
interesting case and you've already
touched on it so I'll go in more depth
in that in a future video but in a
hyperbola is very close in formula to
this and so there's two ways that a
hyperbola could be written and I'll do
those two ways so it could either be
written as x squared over a squared
minus y squared over B squared is equal
to 1 notice the only difference between
equation and this one is that instead of
a plus y squared we have a minus y
squared here so that that would be one
hyperbola the other one would be if the
minus sign was the other way around if
it was y squared over B squared minus x
squared over a squared is equal to one
so now the minus is in front of the x
squared term instead of the y squared
term and what I want to do now is try to
figure out how do we graph these either
of these parabolas maybe we'll do both
cases and in a lot of textbooks or even
if you look it up over the web they'll
give you formulas but I don't like those
formulas one because I'll always forget
it and you'll forget it immediately
after taking the test you might want to
memorize it if you just want to get do
be able to do the test a little bit
faster but you'll forget it and the
second thing is not only you forget it
but you'll probably get confused because
sometimes they always use the a under
the X and the B under the Y or sometimes
they always use the a under the positive
term and the B under the the negative
term so if you just memorize Oh a
divided by B that's the slope of the
asymptote and all of that you might be
using the wrong a and B so I encourage
you to always kind of reprove it to
yourself and that's what we're going to
do right here and it actually doesn't
take too long so these are both
hyperbolas and what I like to do
whenever I have a hyperbola is solve for
y so in this case I get C if I if I
subtract x squared over a squared from
both sides I get let me change the color
I get minus y squared over B squared
alright that stays there is equal to 1
minus x squared over a squared and then
let's see I want to get rid of this
minus and I want to get rid of this B
squared so let's multiply both sides of
this equation x minus B squared all
right if you multiply the left hand side
times minus B squared the minus and the
B squared go away and you're just left
with Y squared is equal to minus B
squared and then minus B squared times a
plus that becomes a plus B squared over
a squared x squared we're almost there
and then you get
why is equal to and I'm doing this on
purpose the plus or minus square root
because it can be the plus or minus
square root of let's switch these around
just so I have this term first a
positive term first V squared over a
squared x squared minus B squared now
what is this you said Sal you know you
said this was simple I'm solving this
this looks like a really complicated
thing but remember we're doing this to
figure out the asymptotes of the
hyperbola just to kind of give you a
sense of where we're going we do it here
I'll do the other actually I want to do
that other hyperbola so a hyperbola if
that's the X that's the y axis it has
two asymptotes and the asymptotes you
know they're they're these lines that
the hyperbola will approach so if that
those are the two asymptotes and they're
always the negative slope of each
other.we we know that a height this
hyperbola is either and we'll show it in
a second which one it is it's either
going to be it's going to look something
like this where as we approach infinity
we get closer and closer to this line
and closer to close to that line and
here it's either going to look like that
I didn't draw it perfectly it never
touches the asymptote just gets closer
and closer and closer arbitrarily close
to the asymptote it's either gonna look
like that where it's kind of one you
know opens up to the right and the left
or or a hyper blues going to open up up
up and down and once again as you go
further and further an asymptote means
it's just closer and closer to one of
these lines without ever touching it but
it'll get infinitely close as you get
infinitely far away as X gets infinitely
large so in order to figure out which
one of these things is let's just think
about what happens as X becomes
infinitely large so if I draw so as X
approaches infinity so as X approaches
infinity or X approaches negative
infinity so I'll say plus or minus
infinity right it doesn't matter because
when you take a negative this gets
squared so this number becomes really
huge as you approach positive or
negative infinity and you'll learn more
about this when we actually do limits
but I think that's intuitive that this
number becomes huge this number is just
a constant it just stays the same so as
you approach as X approaches positive or
negative infinity is it gets really
really large
why is going to be approximately equal
to that's product what I wanted is
actually I think that's congruent let me
I think this is
I always forget notation approximately
this just means not exactly but
approximately equal to when X approaches
infinity it's going to be approximately
equal to the plus or minus the square
root of b squared over a squared x
squared right and that is equal to now
you can take the square root of this you
couldn't take a square root of this
algebraically but this you can this is
equal to plus or minus B over a X so
that tells us essentially what the two
asymptotes are where the slope of one
asymptote will be B over a X this could
give you this positive B over a X and
the other one would be minus B over a X
and I'll do this with some example so it
makes it a little clearer but we still
so we know what the asymptotes look like
it's these two lines right because it's
a plus B ax is one line y equals plus B
ax
let's say it's this one this asymptote
right here is the y is equal to plus B
over ax I know you can't read that and
then the downward sloping asymptotes we
could say is y is equal to minus B over
ax so those are two asymptotes but we
still have to figure out whether the
hyperbola opens up to the left and right
or doesn't open up and down and there at
least there's two ways to kind of do
this one you see well you know this was
an approximation this is what you
approach as you X approaches infinity
but we see here that even when X
approaches infinity we're always going
to be a little bit smaller than that
number because we're subtracting a
positive number from this right we're
subtracting a positive number that when
taking a square root of whole things
we're always going to be a little bit
lower than the asymptote especially when
I guess when we're in kind of the
positive quadrant right so to me that's
how I like to do it I think oh we're
always at least in the positive quadrant
gets a little more confusing when you
went to the other quadrants we're always
going to be a little bit lower than the
asymptote so we're going to approach
from the bottom there and since you know
you're there you know it's going to be
like this and approach this asymptote
and then since it's opening to the right
here it's also going to open to the left
the other way to test it and maybe this
is more intuitive for you is to figure
out in the our original equation could x
or y equal to 0 because when you open to
the right and left notice you never get
to X equal to 0 you always get you get
to y equals 0 right here and here but
you never get to x equals 0 and actually
your teacher might want you to plot
these points and there you just
substitute y equals 0 and that you can
just look at the original equation
actually you could even look at you
could even look it at this equation
right here could X ever equal 0 if you
look at this equation if X is equal to 0
this whole term right here would cancel
out and you just be left with a minus B
squared which is a you're taking B
squared and you put a negative sign in
front of so that's a negative number and
they're taking the square root of a
negative number so we're not dealing
with imaginaries right now so you will
you can never have X equal to 0 so what
Y could be equal to 0 right you could
set y equals 0 and then you could solve
for it so in this case actually let's do
that if Y is equal to 0 you get 0 is
equal to the square root of B squared
over a squared x squared minus B squared
you could square both sides you get B
squared over a squared x squared minus B
squared is equal to 0 and now this is
messy so then you get B squared over a
squared x squared is equal to B squared
you could divide both sides by B squared
I guess you get a 1 and a 1 and then you
could multiply both sides by a squared
you get x squared is equal to a squared
right and then you get X is equal to the
plus or minus square root of a so this
point right here is the point a comma 0
and this point right here is a point
minus a a comma 0 let's go back to the
other asset the other problem I'm a
feeling I might have might be running
out of time so notice that when X when
the X term was positive our hyperbola
opened to the right and the left and you
could probably guess from deductive
reasoning that when the Y term is
positive which is in the case in this
one we're probably going to open up and
down and let's just prove that to
ourselves so solve for y
you get Y squared over B squared we're
going to add x squared over a squared to
both sides so you get equals x squared
over a squared plus 1 multiply both
sides by B squared y squared is equal to
B squared over a squared x squared plus
B squared going to distribute the B
squared now take the square root I'll
switch colors for that so Y is equal to
the plus or minus square root of B
squared over a squared x squared plus B
squared and then once again
oh I've run out of space we can make
that same argument that as X approaches
infinity as X approaches positive or
negative infinity X approaches positive
or negative infinity this equation this
be this little constant term right here
isn't going to matter as much you're
just going to take the square root of
this term right here which is
essentially B over a X plus or minus B
over a X and once again those are these
same two asymptotes which I'll redraw
here that line and that line but in this
case we're always a little bit larger
than the asymptotes
we're always a little bit larger than
the asymptotes especially in the
positive quadrant that tells us we're
going to be up here and down there and
another way to think about it in this
case when the hyperbola is vertical or
you know it's a vertical hyperbola where
you're always kind of it opens up and
down you notice X could be equal to 0
but Y could never be equal to 0 and that
makes sense too because if you look at
our original formula right here X could
be equal to 0 if X was 0 this would
cancel out you could just solve for y
but if Y we're equal to 0 you would have
minus x squared over a squared is equal
to 1 and then you would have if you
solve this you would get x squared is
equal to minus a squared and we're not
dealing with imaginary number so you
can't square something you can't get a
negative number so once again this would
be impossible so that's the other clue
that tells you it opens up and down
because in this case why couldn't
equals zero anyway you might be a little
confused because I stayed abstract with
the bees and the A's in the next couple
of videos I'll do a bunch of problems
where we draw a bunch of hyperbolas
ellipses and circles with actual numbers
see you soon